some quarantine sex tips wouldn't really
hit the spot right now from row
[Music]
quarantine sex there oh he's asleep Ryan
I just took some horny goat weed I think
all the Bloods fresh out on my head to
my [ __ ] I think you can hear us you have
computer rowdy unmute yourself Ronnie's
never had a computer before
what is this okay let me do the old man
thing and lift my glasses
all right he's escaped where's command
quit floors control option number three
Amazon Prime check on order for horny
goat weed Robert Lee unavailable what
the [ __ ] bottom left there's a
microphone unmuted unmute Ronnie Ronnie
you're on all right right never mind
Jimmy sorry no sex Ronnie's got it
glasses up and he's trying to see how to
unmute the zoom I could watch that for
an hour
[Laughter]
Jason just wrote me he said no one can
unmute Ronnie for him he's got to do it
himself and as you can see Ronnie is
right it's not gonna
he's completely freaked out by the
computer and and in the lower-left
Ronnie it says mute all you have to do
is hit the [ __ ] button there's a
microphone there's a little symbol of a
microphone [ __ ] he thought there was a
vibrator version that is the problem
anyway I'm guys my blackberry version I
did it we see didn't know [ __ ]
[Applause]
couldn't find the button that says
unmute no no I screw up the whole screen
I don't know what I did
well we were watching you the whole time
Oh rewriting what a camera crystal yeah
did you see me jerking off